-It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So, this week, I sent out
the hashtag, #MyWorstCar,
and we asked you guys to tell us
a weird or funny story
about a bad car that you owned.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic
in the U.S. for a long time.
So thank you so much
for playing along again.
It's fun for us.
The hashtag was #MyWorstCar,
and so people were just all
talking about their worst car.
But what I found from
reading all of these,
really, a lot of them --
many of them ended with,
"I loved that car" or
"I miss that car."
So, these are tweets -- This is
more of a salute
to all the cars out there
that we love and miss.
So now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#MyWorstCar responses
from you guys.
This first one's from
@taradublinrocks.
She says...
[ Laughs ]
"Mr. Potato Car."
That's a good idea for a toy.
This one's from @pyokes.
He says...
Ford Escape.
This one's from @Mamalafafala.
-What?
-She says...
That's so --
That's so "Mario Kart."
That's so fun.
This one's from @nevertrev.
"Hey, Trev,
you want go out tonight
and get something to eat?
-Never.
-I understand. We're cool, man.
He says...
"Hey, I think it's raining."
♪♪
"Hey, Fabio, it's not raining.
It's fine."
"Are you sure?
Let me just wipe
the windshield."
-♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪ Windshields ♪
-"Someone's under arrest."
"What?"
"Trevor, do you want to
give me a ride to school?"
-Never.
♪♪
-This one's from @bekahjonelson.
She says...
"Why did you order
the fire sauce?"
This one's from @NBRieth.
She says...
-What?
-So you -- What?
Gas with your left and then --
What is going on?
That sounds good.
This one's from @kimyarbrough.
She says...
Yeah.
Fier-r-ro.
This one's from @sarah schaefer.
She says...
-Wait a minute.
How do you figure that out?
That's what I was going to say.
How did you figure that out?
"That's how much time
we spent in our car."
They're like, "Whoa!
I could turn the horn off."
This one's from @LaurelVerchuk.
She says...
Pretty good. That's good.
This one's from @mmklintworth.
She says...
Here's a video.
[ Laughing ] Oh, my God!
"We need gas.
No, we're full.
Now we need gas.
No, we're going 150."
-Yeah.
-This last one's from
@reneejordan78.
She said...
There you have it.
Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.